hi in this video I'm going to show you
how to download image a software an
image a software is a very cool image
editing tool and using image a we can
analyze the data for confocal microscopy
we can analyze the data of Western blot
any other type of chain we can do 10 0
metric analysis we can also perform
radio we can also analyze radiological
data so in order to download image J
first go to your web browser and then go
to the search bar and type image J so
then click on the image J so it would
open our nih website click on that there
is an option for download there a
separate option for mac and separate
option for windows and in under the
windows there option for both 32-bit
computers and 64-bit computers as my
computer is 64-bit and it runs java one
point 8.0 that is why i want to click on
this particular version and i would
click on it after clicking on it you can
see it start downloading that option and
i as i have downloaded it previously i
would directly show you from there so i
have downloaded these application so
when we click on that particular
application it would say image there is
a folder for image chain and there is
image exe file that is a set of file for
image j
click on that and it would automatically
extract that file and install it up
straight after installing it allow it
access an image j would be ready and
here you can see this is the image a
toolbar there is image a toolbar it's
not very fancy looking but it's very
useful in my next video i will show you
how to use this image analysis tool to
perform various kinds of kami
analysis I hope this video was helpful
for helpful for you if you liked my
video please give it a quick thumbs up
don't forget to subscribe and please
share thank you